the reason why I'm sort of changing
gears again is because we started off by
first identifying what the pentominoes
are we mostly got there and then we now
have a complete list and now at the
moment we've been trying to distinguish
between the pentominoes and say well
some of these characteristics and others
have different characteristics right so
I'm going to show you in a second what
each one is and there are vegetables and
animals and minerals okay but I'm
expecting once I show you there might be
some arguments so here's my breakdown
I'd love you to have a quick comparison
with what you think each of them is I
count if you want to quickly check for
yourself
I count 1 2 3 4 minerals 1 2 vegetables
and then the rest are animals Jessica
you ever thought the giraffe yep yes can
I ask how many other people think this
is a vegetable yeah a few other people
can't decide yet okay so so let's think
about this this is a great question and
I really want you're switching on to
this because this is where the thinking
is involved right this is why we did
this task so I want to make sure
everyone's eyes are up cuz I'm gonna do
something other board so you can see it
okay it Mary it's like oh I get it okay
so before I show you before I try to
convince you that this is actually an
animal okay let's think about how you
convinced yourself that it was a
vegetable because many people have
convinced themselves right you've only
got three options right shaaka there are
three options yeah three options so I
know very good I know some of you what
you would do is you would say I'm going
to eliminate options right for example
I'm going to try and eliminate that this
is a mineral most people don't think
it's a mineral because what would you do
to the giraffe
what would you do
okay I'm gonna take the head of the
draft this is the top right and I'm
gonna move it down here where the legs
were now my giraffe is upside down this
is the new head so we know this guy can
move back and forth yes so we at least
can rule out that this is a mineral so
in mathematics often we try to find a
solution and it can be easier to
eliminate some possibilities than to try
and find out what the correct one is
okay so we know it's at least a
vegetable we haven't ruled out that it's
an animal can someone who's seen it
somebody's seen it tell me now what can
I do I've already done one move what can
I do further to actually get it away
from its position Louise what do you see
this this middle part here yep yeah okay
so it was here before can you see them
move that when Louise is describing
she's saying okay they're like I don't
know I guess the the in-between part is
becoming a difference in between part
very good so at the moment it's still
sort of in place but now I can sort of
continue that same move and my giraffe
is how would you describe this I guess
it's kind of like doing I don't know
like back flips or something I don't
know it's clearly getting out of it
isn't it okay it's like digging into the
ground so this I know this I know is I
mean come on I gave you guys a clue I
called it a giraffe right anyway some
people like it's a fruit wait what are
the fruits I don't know what fruits on
ok now we have we've got 10 minutes left
and now we're going to do the hardest
version of the pentameter problem okay
and this is actually this is the real
primary reason why I gave you this piece
of paper okay so remember we introduced
this when we just looked at all the
polyominoes right and I showed you you
could combine polyominoes into a
rectangle right now can you have a look
at the dimensions of these rectangles
one of the dimensions they're all the
same one can you count them up they are
very large can you cut them up
so 10 times 6 right now I didn't choose
that coincidentally ball way back then I
was laying a seed I was planting a seed
for now right Lia's just realized have a
look at these pentominoes again have a
look again how many pentominoes are
there each one has 5 squares so how many
squares are on the screen right now
there are 60 exactly the same number as
are in these rectangles so here's your
final challenge okay take take your grid
paper and cut out all 12 of the
pentominoes and see if you can arrange
them into a perfect rectangle you're
definitely going to need to work
together for this good luck
[Music]
imagine I always trying to solve the
puzzle and I've done this see where my
shapes are can you see my shaded
pentominoes I've only put two patatas in
but you can already tell me that this
will not lead to a solution think about
it
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 squares left in the
corner why is this a problem why is it
Jessica yeah if I put in one shape
I've still got leftovers I can't put
into cos then it overlap this will help
you the last thing I want to show you is
just to encourage you to say yes it's
totally possible okay there's not just
one way
there are many and in fact I really want
to encourage you and say I am going to
predict that many of you are going to
get different solutions and that's
actually part of the challenge thank you
you're right please make sure your
scraps are in the recycling